Для неї спогади про Майдан уособлені в цій світлині.
Фото зроблене вранці 20 лютого 2014-го.
Медсестра-волонтерка Майдану Олеся Жуковська
приходить на барикади біля Лядських воріт
на чергування і опиняється під вогнем снайпера.
Куля влучила їй у шию.
- Зачепило гілку сонної артерії і слинну залозу.
Чоловік на фото - це мій знайомий Стас.
Він одразу з хлопцями взяв мене на руки.
Пощастило теж, що швидка стояла поряд,
що була вільна, це просто щастя.
Бо якби не це, то там вже йшло на секунди.
Олеся родом з Тернопільщини.
Під час Революції гідності їй саме виповнився 21 рік.
Уперше опинилася на Майдані
після жорстокого побиття студентів у ніч на 30 листопада.
Таких, як вона, молодих дівчат на Майдані були сотні, якщо не тисячі.
Медсестри, які витягували з-під вогню снайперів поранених.
Жінки, що словами намагалися зупинити беркутівців,
які жорстоко били активістів. Як це робила
героїня Небесної сотні, 62-річна Антоніна Дворянець
із Броварів. 18 лютого вона отримала поранення, несумісні з життям.
28-річна Ольга Бура з Львівщини померла
від зараження крові. Вона розбирала бруківку для будівництва барикад.
71-річна Людмила Шеремет отримала смертельне поранення
на хмельницькому Майдані під час акції протесту
біля місцевого СБУ.
Жінки та дівчата шукали теплий одяг, шоломи
та щити для захисників барикад, робили коктейлі Молотова,
готували їжу, підносили теплий чай на передові барикади.
Так робила Вікторія Романчук із Волині. Їй тоді було лише 15.
Дівчина каже, що саме на Майдані побачила інших -
активних і мужніх жінок, які ламали стереотипи,
які часто робили неможливе, аби Майдан вистояв.
- Хлопці тримали щити, а ми були там, за ними.
Ми стали опорою і таким дійсно тилом. Не таким,
що сидить вдома  і чекає, а який захищає і допомагає.
Вікторія була в лавах сотні "Волинська січ".
18 лютого, коли вона разом з іншими намагалася зупинити правоохоронців,
отримала поранення ось тут, біля Будинку профспілок.
- Мені під ноги прилетіла граната.
Я не одразу зрозуміла, що це таке.
Просто спалах світла, в мене одразу темрява в очах, я втратила свідомість.
Контузія, більше півсотні рваних ран… З тіла дівчини
лікарі ще досі виймають уламки гранати. У ті дні
з її сотні загинуло шестеро хлопців. Жити далі
з тими спогадами було нелегко, зізнається Вікторія.
Їй допомогли спорт, туризм та кохання.
Її чоловік - теж майданівець. А ще - творчість.
Каже, що живопис для неї - найкраща психотерапія.
Після перемоги Майдану вона закінчила академію мистецтв,
має вже свої виставки. Цього року на п’ятиріччя Майдану
вона привезла до Києва виставку під назвою "Сторожа".
Ідея, яку вона хотіла втілити ще з 2014-го року.
12 сучасних апостолів - як пам'ять про загиблих героїв Небесної сотні,
а також її бачення результатів Майдану.
- Почався процес створення, почалася реально
розбудова країни. Так, можливо, не такими
швидкими темпами, як би нам хотілося, чи ми б того
очікували, але воно відбувається. Навіть якби я знала,
що зі мною таке трапиться, я би ще двічі пішла, аби
запустити ці процеси, аби щось дійсно відбувалося. Воно вартує того.
20 лютого 2014-го медсестра Майдану Олеся Жуковська
одразу після поранення написала в соцмережі : "Я вмираю".
Вона думала, що це її прощальний меседж світу.
Повідомлення розійшлося тисячними репостами.
Олесю підтримали неймовірно багато незнайомих людей.
Це допомогло їй впоратися з ускладненнями від поранення,
не впасти в депресію
і головне: вона навчилася цінувати життя.
Після Майдану вона кардинально змінилася:
спорт, правильне харчування, скинула 20 кілограмів,
навчається в медуніверситеті, бере участь у курсах із саморозвитку.
Їй сумно бачити, що суспільство потроху починає
забувати події на Майдані. Іноді чує
не зовсім приємні речі на свою адресу, коли
для безкоштовного проїзду показує у транспорті
ось це посвідчення учасниці бойових дій -
саме такий статус мають важкопоранені на Майдані.
Або коли вкотре приходить до слідчих, які досі
так і не встановили тих, хто стріляв у неї.
- Я не думаю, що це можливо.
По тій кулі, що тоді взяли, з’ясували, що це Беркут,
зброя ця знищена, а сама особа перебуває на території РФ.
Тим не менше, Олеся, як і Вікторія, вірить
у незворотність реформ. Головне, каже, щоб війна
на Донбасі , на якій досі гинуть її друзі з Майдану,
якнайшвидше завершилася. І щоб
на президентських виборах у березні до влади прийшов гідний кандидат.